as america faces the triple challenges
of a pandemic historic
unemployment and a reckoning over
systemic racism
we wanted to talk to someone who's
trying to help darren walker is the
president of the ford foundation the
organization is devoted to social
justice
and the arts it does not take donations
instead the foundation
with a 13 billion dollar endowment gives
away
at least half a billion dollars a year
the money goes to groups like the
naacp's legal defense fund
the equal justice initiative and the
smithsonian
this year the group is giving away even
more
we spoke with walker at the
organization's empty headquarters
in new york city yeah you want to go to
my office yeah let's go over there
darren walker heads one of the
wealthiest charities
in the world i love this you rest you
rest that's right
and the other is pressure is a privilege
and that's
something i firmly believe in this
tumultuous year
walker felt the pressure to give more
than usual
so the foundation made a bold move
to borrow a billion dollars we had to
figure out
a strategy to give away more money
so we issued the first ever social bond
by a foundation
was that scary no it wasn't scary it was
necessary
we're at a time when foundations
have to do more the question
in 2020 for wealthy privileged people
and institutions
is not how much do i give back
it's how much am i willing to give up
are you willing to give up your
privilege
walker asked in a recent new york times
op-ed
in which he described being at a black
tie charity event
you write in that piece i had the
ominous sense that we were eating
lobster
on the titanic that's a sinking ship
unless we recognize
the need to build a more equal america
we will be eating lobster on the titanic
because we will all go down detroit
declared bankruptcy today it's the
largest american city
ever to do that in 2014 after detroit
declared bankruptcy
the ford foundation committed 125
million dollars
to the city did it work the city is
challenged
but when you consider that seven years
ago
the street lights weren't working
garbage
wasn't being picked up i think we can
say that it was worth it
ford car or truck is the lowest possible
cost
the foundation started with the profits
of the ford motor company in 1936
has long been committed to social
justice
on the walls of its new york
headquarters is a 1963
ad from a new orleans newspaper and it
said
notice to all white citizens stop
buying ford cars and trucks this was
directly targeting the ford foundation
absolutely because the ford foundation
was seen as
a financier of civil rights integration
and civil rights the foundation is now
independent of ford
but walker knows like the country itself
it carries
a complicated legacy i'm lucky enough to
lead a foundation that was founded
by a man who was a notorious
anti-semite and racist but he was
also a great industrialist i'm able to
hold
both narratives and you're saying as a
country we need to embrace our flaws
because we are as a nation both of those
narratives the 60-year-old walker who
now wields
great influence in powerful circles
came from modest beginnings how did
a gay black kid from texas with a single
mom
make it here
let me get emotional walker's mother was
a nurse's
assistant she was determined that i'd be
in head start what did she know about
head start
well she knew that a lady in 1965
walked up to our little shotgun house in
ames texas
and told her about this new program that
president johnson
had put in place for kids like me yeah
that was all she needed to hear walker
went on to the university of texas
and a career on wall street before
turning to philanthropy
america is not just a country
america is an idea the idea
of mobility and a better life
for your children we are asphyxiating
that idea
walker sees something changing in the
country
after the death of george floyd at the
hands of police
racism is no longer deniable
you work with a lot of white americans
do you think they're ready
to confront racism i am hearing
ceos leaders across this country
talk about racism in ways i have never
heard them we're in uncomfortable
conversations
and that is going to be the first step
that allows us
to begin to excavate and heal
as a nation it's so interesting what
darren walker and the ford foundation
are doing by borrowing this money to
give away more most foundations are
actually trying to they're trying to
protect their assets right now
being very careful in a very turbulent
economy he's like no
we're needed more than ever we got to
get out there and he's putting his money
where his mouth is is he stepping
further in areas he hadn't stepped
before
i i think by well by borrowing money and
it hasn't been done
by a philanthropy like that before he he
is but he
he's being very vocal about fundamental
change that needs to come
not just in philanthropies but but by
the people who run the country
and have advantages that other people
don't okay well i know he
is a lover of the arts he is a lover of
history you'd be interested
to see where that money goes great story
you're